morning fred smells like christmas
it is the most wonderful time of the
year again holiday films on repeat
if you're looking for a fresh new
addition to step up your usual
elf love actually holiday movie binge
then look no further than 2018's
animated family movie
the grinch oh mr grinch i'm so happy you
decided to come
it is a more modern and humorous take on
the classic dr seuss tale how the grinch
stole
christmas as an added bonus this movie
is full of a star-studded cast
their voices sound so familiar you're
sure you can put your finger on it but
others may surprise you i say something
like yeah yeah yeah have a nice life
it may come as a surprise that english
actor benedict cumberbatch
stars as the story's infamous mean one
mr grinch
cumberbatch has a lengthy history in
global television and film
with some of his most notable roles
being sherlock holmes in sherlock and dr
steven strange and doctor strange he
also gave an impressive performance as
smaug in the hobbit where not only was
his voice acting top-notch but they also
used motion capture where he physically
acted like a real dragon
you have nice manners
he was also nominated for best actor at
the 2015 oscars for his role as alan
turing in the imitation game
so having benedict voice the grinch
couldn't be better
behold the present this is
our enemy his dialogue as the grinch is
humorous how much emotional eating have
i been doing
and he delivers a seamless american
accent even though his natural british
accent is quite thick
i don't speak ridiculous oh you're a
scream have a nice life goodbye
it honestly fooled us completely and we
would never have guessed that it was him
rashida jones daughter of musician
quincy jones and actress peggy lipton
has been acting since the late 1990s
some of her most recognizable roles
include comedic hits such as ann perkins
in parks and recreation
and her role as karen phillippelli in
the office are we taking this too far
you know what i don't think we're taking
this far enough she has had a long
prosperous career in cinema and
television
starring alongside andy samberg and
celeste and jesse forever and appeared
in the historical drama the social
network
as marilyn deppley in the grinch she
voices donna who
the loving nurse and hardworking super
mom of cindy luhu and brothers buster
and bean
okay then well good luck and i guess
i'll see you in
about a month joan's voice is memorably
iconic
and she captures donna who's spirit with
a bubbly but raspy undertone
okay come take your seats everyone
dinner's ready in the grinch the titular
main protagonist
cindy luhu is voiced by 13 year old
cameron seely
celie's voice takes on the character's
childlike spirit while also portraying
the more modern humorous perspective of
this movie's version
cindy lou don't worry mom
she is a junior actor and singer just
breaking into her cinematic career in
film
but she has already done so with a huge
bang she has already worked on the
greatest showman
alongside hollywood a-list actors like
zendaya hugh jackman and zac efron
she also starred in the jim gaffigan
show before landing the leading role in
the grinch
thank you santa good night
the happy singer pharrell williams the
seemingly ageless musical icon
stars as the narrator for this movie it
is christmas in whoville
the home of the whos pharrell is a
multi-grammy winner and nominee
he has over 10 wins and 40 nominations
to his name
he's known for his musical hits like
blurred lines and feels but this
talented composer has also worked on the
soundtracks for the despicable me
trilogy
the oscar-nominated film hidden figures
and the amazing spider-man 2.
along with being a judge on the voice
williams is also a popular music writer
and producer
he's helped write hits like get lucky
drop it like it's hot and i'm a slave
for you
his narration in this classic movie
adaptation is something we didn't know
we needed but
thoroughly enjoyed in three weeks
through december
this place hits its stride his smooth
voice glides us around the story holds
it all together
and adds the touch of coziness required
for this holiday special
and the luscious sound swelled reaching
up to the skies
veteran funnyman keenan thompson plays a
new kooky addition to the grinch
franchise
he portrays the overly zealous christmas
obsessed mr bricklebomb
thompson's natural sense of humor made
this an obviously fitting casting choice
i myself use chocolate explosion
he is a long time cast member of
saturday night live and has also
appeared in various television series
he has starred in the unbreakable kimmy
schmidt as the character ronald and has
also lent his voice to television shows
such as nature cat and scooby-doo and
guess who
kanan's naturally smiley warm voice
brought the character of mr bricklebaum
to life
come on bridget give me a hug it don't
count if you don't hug
back buddy you may not immediately
recognize the name
angela lansbury but you may recognize
her voice she is best known for her
portrayal as mrs potts
in disney's 1991 oscar-nominated film
beauty and the beast
after the cupboard with you now chip is
past your bedtime
she also starred as aunt adelaide in
nanny mcphee and she also appeared in
the 2018 version of mary poppins
then you've forgotten what it's like to
hold a balloon
to be a child lansbury is a longtime
actress in television film
and voice she has been in the game since
the early 1940s and has starred in films
such as the three musketeers and the
private affairs of bellamy during that
time
she has a collection of awards
nominations and accolades including a
television critics association
lifetime achievement award in the grinch
movie she lent her voice to the
character
mayor mcgurkel her charming voice made
the character more robust and jovial
it is time to light this beautiful tree
some viewers might not have guessed that
max the grinch's furry sidekick
was voiced by long-time voice actor
frank welker he's a legend in the world
of voice acting
you might recognize welker's voice if
you enjoy watching the mystery solving
gang in the scooby-doo franchise
frank is most known for his voice as
fred jones in the series
he has also done work for many other
childhood favorites
such as curious george animatics the
simpsons
bubble guppies and smurfs the lost
village he has also worked on numerous
other projects like the flintstones and
the transformers franchise
you let the talisman get away
he has been working in both television
and film since the late 1960s
and won a daytime emmy lifetime
achievement award in 2016 as a testament
to his work
so having this iconic voice actor play
max that was an easy choice
what santa had that i don't
scarlett estevez is most widely known
for her role as megan in daddy's home
and daddy's home too
she also appeared as trixie espinoza and
lucifer
estevez voiced one of cindy lou who's
good friends izzy in the animated grinch
movie
all right we're in great now let's do
this
izzy is also the twin sibling to brother
ozzy this isn't scarlett's first go at
voiceover work either
she also lent her voice in the tv short
animated series
if you give a mouse a cookie and the
anime series modest heroes
the role of ozzy is portrayed by sam
lavagnino
lavanino was born in 2006 and has since
appeared in television and film before
he landed his role on the grinch
come on it's not the school play dude he
appeared in the bravest warriors
and the disney series miles from
tomorrow he also lent his voice to the
peanuts movie
where he was part of the group voices
axel is part of cindy lou who's trio of
friends
which includes twins izzy and ozzy ramon
hamilton voiced the part of axel in the
grinch
what are you talking about personally
annie has appeared in hot in cleveland
blaze and the monster machine and modern
family
so what did you think of the grinch's
casting choices did any of the choices
surprise you or did you agree or
disagree with any of the picks
let us know what you think in the
comments below if you enjoyed this video
please make sure to give it a like and
don't forget to subscribe to see more
content like this
make sure to click that bell icon so you
get notifications when we post new
videos
until next time thanks for watching